the united states right now i don't
believe i
haven't looked at those figures in a
while but i don't think that the united
states is the largest
polluter in the world i think that china
and india are above us
now here you have four and a half
billion people um
who are trying to get rich quick and who
are spewing a lot of co2 into the
atmosphere
and who are also very competitive with
us because they have very low wages
so to tie ourselves to the paris climate
accord
uh was the wrong way to go about it and
you know what else happened
was that the united states has decreased
its emissions
of co2 per capita at a faster pace than
most
places in the world why because we
started
we started getting rid of our
coal-powered plants and we started
introducing more and more natural gas
into our electricity production and
natural gas
burns or rather emits much less co2 than
coal
and so by simply by innovating
by basically changing the source of fuel
from coal to natural gas
we were able to decrease our co2
emissions at a faster click
than we would have been obliged to do
under paris
one of the interesting things about this
trend i thought was that
your answer basically said sort of trust
that human ideas can solve problems and
that in many ways
is so counter to what we hear coming out
of the left now you know we hear about
the
the green new deal and that that this
centralized planning thing
can somehow magically just sort of solve
all of these problems if we just gave it
enough power
but it but in many ways you're well
power and money of course
but in many ways what you're saying is
you decentralize things you let people
come up with new ideas and suddenly
we'll have a thinner can and less
resources will be taken and it'll
actually
be cheaper and they'll be more readily
available
the answer to climate change is not
going to come from central planning
and from restrictions for two reasons
let's divide the world into two
halves in one half you have
rich people like you and i relatively
rich obviously
living in democracies now we are
prepared
to pay a little more for the protection
of the environment
we are willing to put up with taxes
which are a little bit higher
but not much higher in fact all the
opinion polls
and and surveys suggest that people are
willing to put up a little more toward
uh toward cleaning of the climate what
they are not prepared to do
is to end the first world lifestyles
as they know it on uh for the benefit of
uh
of of uh environment or climate change
so isn't that in essence what was
happening in france that they kept
raising taxes on gas
to to do climate initiatives and that
that basically started riot
and then you got the rights to jill
homer and um so
um and so there is this one half
rich people in democracies will not vote
to end civilization full stop
then you have the second half of the
world uh let's say
very poor people or relatively poor
people who live in countries which are
not democracies
places like that places like china and
places like india
the governments there are not going to
forego
the possibility of rapid economic growth
and becoming rich
just because people in rich countries
demand that
we should demand it of them because it
is immoral
and those governments are not going to
do it because they are not suicidal
even china which is a totalitarian and
awful regime
and which keeps saying we are going to
go carbon free by this state and other
day
they are building a record number of uh
coal-powered power plants as we speak in
other words they understand
that there is nothing sure
to destroy the communist party's hold on
power
than denying the chinese people a better
life
yeah is that sort of an offshoot of
the the rationale that got us out of the
paris accords that in essence
these countries were going to keep doing
these things because they had to do them
as they go through their industrial
revolutions talking say about china and
india
while we were going to put regulations
on ourselves and and pay for the brunt
of it
and there was no enforcement mechanism
and everything else
i think that was a part of it is that
there is the the united states right now
i don't believe
i haven't looked at those figures in a
while but i don't think that the united
states is the largest
polluter in the world i think that china
and india are above us
now here you have four and a half
billion people um
who are trying to get rich quick and who
are spewing a lot of co2 into the
atmosphere
and who are also very competitive with
us because they have very low wages
so to tie ourselves to the paris climate
accord
uh was the wrong way to go about it and
you know what else happened
was that the united states has decreased
its emissions of co2 per capita
at a faster pace than most places in the
world why
because we started we started getting
rid of our coal powered plants and we
started introducing more and more
natural gas
into our electricity production and
natural gas
burns or rather emits much less co2 than
coal
and so by simply by innovating
by basically changing the source of fuel
from coal to natural gas
we were able to decrease our co2
emissions at a faster click
than we would have been obliged to do
under paris
all right so let's move on to trend
number four i thought this was
interesting because i see a lot of talk
of this kind of thing online related to
peak population and that we're we're
putting too many people on this earth
is it true it is
not true um right now there are 7.8
billion of us
the global population will peak in about
2060 2070 at roughly
nine nine and a half billion and then it
will start declining
there are a number of studies done on
this the latest one came from landsat
which is a very highly regarded british
medical paper
and what they have concluded is that by
2100
there will be anywhere between 6.8 and
8.8
billion people in the world so roughly 1
billion less
than we have today or 1 billion more i'm
very ambivalent about this trend
because i think that because humans are
the only
entities in the world capable of
actually producing ideas
if you're going to come up with a cure
for cancer if you're going to come up
for a solution to climate change and
fusion reactor
you need a human brain to do that
artificial intelligence is simply not
there yet
so fewer human beings we have
the harder it will be to produce enough
geniuses to come up with
ideas to solve our problems nonetheless
the reality is
that the total fertility rate which is
to say the
number of babies that a woman can expect
to have
in her life is now roughly around 2.4
replacement level is 2.1
replacement level basically means that
if you have fewer babies than that
the global population starts declining
in europe
in places like czech republic where my
ancestors are from or slovakia
the total fertility rate is 1.3 1.4
rather than 2.1 which is needed just to
keep the population steady
and the only place really which is above
2.1 2.4 is africa population of africa
is still going to increase for a while
but globally we have fewer and fewer
babies being born per woman why is that
is because women are getting education
and they are getting
work what happens when a woman gets work
is that the opportunity
cost of staying at home and taking care
of children increases
she can do with her life other things
she can earn a lot of money
in the marketplace and so she has fewer
and fewer babies
this relationship uh is
we are seeing it no matter which
continent uh you are looking at
if we see it everywhere and we expect
that as
africa becomes richer african women will
start having
fewer and fewer babies below the
replacement level
yeah some of this stuff feels like it
must be it must be hard to track because
if you were to say okay
let's look a hundred years in the future
and with the trends of how people
are reproducing right now well all sorts
of other
trends change and food changes and
migration patterns change and everything
else so that
that explains why it could be one
billion over or under right
correct it is also based on uh on on
assumptions about economic growth and
access to education
we expect that the economy will continue
to grow i mean if the economy stops
growing or if there is a de-growth
in certain parts of the world then the
relationship between
increased wealth and fewer babies
obviously ends
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about the
environment
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our environment playlist and if you want
to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell